by the end of the Second World War it
was clear to many in Britain that Indian
independence was inevitable a notable
exception being Winston Churchill who
wanted India to remain a British
Dominion at all costs and for all time
but since he had just been voted out of
office no one really cared what he
thought anymore he was replaced by
Clement Attlee he was sympathetic to
Indian independence and so as Prime
Minister he began the process that would
lead to it of course there's one thing
you'll have noticed about British India
before and after independence it was
partitioned the question is why now
before continuing it's important to
clear up some common misconceptions the
first is that Ceylon now Sri Lanka was
not a part of British India although it
did achieve independence at the same
time the second is that Burma had
previously been a part of British India
but was by the end of the second world
war administered separately the third
thing to make clear is that Britain
didn't rule rule of India directly some
of it was ruled by Indian princes like
in Hyderabad so British India was
incredibly diverse and was home to many
people's languages and religions
although frankly this was mostly lost on
the British who largely saw everyone as
being under one category ours there were
many of these peoples calling for
independence from Britain but very few
were Pro partition the British Viceroy
in India in 1947 was Lord Mountbatten
who alongside aptly wanted an
independent India to remain united so it
would make a stronger ally in the Cold
War the pro-independence Indian National
Congress was opposed to division since
they felt it would weaken India the main
proponents of partition with the Muslim
League led by Muhammad Ali Jinnah Jinnah
believed that since an independent India
would be overwhelmingly Hindu the rights
in each of the country's Muslim minority
would be trampled on thus to him it was
necessary for the creation of an
independent Muslim state could Pakistan
in case you're wondering the name
Pakistan is a sort of acronym made up of
the majority Muslim states in Northwest
India Punjab Afghani a Kashmir Indus
Sindh and the tan comes from Baluchistan
tensions continued to rise throughout
India as demands for independence and
also for an independent Muslim state
continued to grow after winning an India
wide election the Indian National
Congress largely refused to negotiate
with the Muslim League and the British
were mostly looking to keep their hands
clean at this stage as violence
continued to break out no one was able
to keep the idea of a united India alive
and so in the end the inevitable was
agreed to upon its independence India
was to be partitioned into at least two
countries as such the reasons for Indian
partition are quite clear it was the
desire of the Muslim minority within
India to have control over its own
affairs and
fear that their rights wouldn't be
protected that divided the subcontinent
so now that the Y has been established
our attention should turn to the how
because one of the most controversial
things about partition was how the new
nation's borders were drawn the task
fell to the British and Lord Mountbatten
and it was decided that all of the
states within India were to have three
options join India join Pakistan or to
become independent states most opted for
the first two but some states most
notably Hyderabad and Kashmir wished to
be independent the districts of Bengal
and Punjab would be divided in the
relevant Hindu and Muslim populations
there were to be resettled from one
country to another many in India and
Pakistan were concerned about the
population transfer becoming violent but
Britain promised there wouldn't be any
problems
a promise that wasn't within their power
to honor I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with extra
thanks to my patrons that you see on
screen now and a special thanks to James
Bissonnette David archaeologist
Zarqa flash Party Boyko Rob Waterhouse
Yashar Enderman Chris wicker mouths
Bailey Brent guard Michael Reynolds
Gustav Swan tune Rick onion duck Maggie
pax Kowski Winston Cawood vasily era
Vedas Anthony Beckett Adam Harvey Ike
Skye Chappelle and the amusement park
Ives